alright guys bangbang I've got Michael
here we've been hanging out for a little
bit so we figured we Pasha turn the
microphones on and start uh start
actually recording thank you for so much
for coming to do this we got tons to
talk about and frankly I want to learn
about etf's I'm super excited to be here
I made the last 45 minutes we've covered
so much so I think it's way to get into
the real meat of it all so we pretty
much already recorded the podcast you
guys missed out but alright let's start
with your background and kind of how you
got to ETFs and then we can get into
exactly what's going on there ok so um I
guess at this point I'm kind of known as
the ETF nerd I gave us some little
trinkets out earlier but how do we get
there my background I actually grew up
in North Carolina oh so did I where
North Connick Charlotte I did spend some
time in Chapel Hill I know you guys have
that presence there I went to NC State
actually not very cool I was a Duke fan
that triangle sorry there every friend I
had was a Carolina fan or a state fan
and they all thought I was weird for me
to do I when I was a kid I was pretty
good at chess and debate and that paid
for me to go to school and I studied
philosophy and religion certainly didn't
ever think I would be in this industry
really wait how do you get to school on
chess and debate they give scholarships
really yeah for chess or to be her mom I
got the primary money for debate yeah
but they still wanted me playing on the
chess team however there is this thing
called girls and the chests didn't work
as well but it's nice because you know
chess translates into a lot of other
things yes I want to have a debate for a
second because to me it was always like
they were trying to teach people how to
argue and it seems like the people who
are just good at arguing to begin with
like had this natural inclination but
the education of how are
your debate didn't really see pin in
like high school etc did you have a
different experience actually going
through it no you're a hundred percent
right it was it was really process um my
we said we'd go some rabbit holes here
so here's one my proudest moment and
debate was I was at Berkeley for a
tournament and I got the first ever tie
what is that
so does that nobody ever thought there
could be a tie yeah right and I was
losing bad and the argument they were
making against me was a critique of my
language that the way I was going about
trying to win this debate was oppressing
them hey and I was like well then there
can't be a winner and I want to tie they
determine who the winner is the judge
there's a just single judge said well in
the final rounds there's usually three
judges okay but in the you know usually
you do like six rounds and then you're
in the finals but that that's my
crowning achievement the first ever tie
that's pretty good yeah well maybe it'd
be better to win but at I was definitely
I got it alright see you go to school
chess debate etc what do you do after
school so uh my grandmother passed his
way and my grandfather's left up here
alone and I think before I figure out
what I'm gonna do with my life let me go
to New York and let's take care of my
grandfather first summer and I had this
friend from my childhood who was there
and he was driving a Lexus and you know
the the joey tribianni kind of
stereotype that was this guy and i'm
like what do you do he goes I work on
the stock exchange I go what do you do
there he goes I don't know that that's I
wish I was kidding I'm not gonna say his
name yeah human but uh so and he was
just like a classic New Yorker slicked
back hair gold chain the everything I'm
envisioning right now and everything
whip in the Lexus work on the stock
exchange floor probably slamming
doughnuts in the morning the whole nine
yards write it write it in 1999 yeah
1999 2000 money falling from the sky
bonuses are inflated yep I mean and he
didn't know what he did I know what he
did what did he actually do he was a
clerk for susquehanna or bear hunter I
don't think it exists anymore but yeah
it became Goldman
something and so what are the clerks do
nothing anymore they barely exist I mean
that that's all been digitized but when
I saw that I said I'm gonna write a book
about how horrible Wall Street is and
all these terrible things like
philosophy religion this is this is my
chance to tell the world how terrible
this is [ __ ] capitalist welcome all
right well here's where the story turns
right so then I make two or three phone
calls I get an internship my grandmother
buys me the worst sport coat I could
ever imagine the other grandmother not
the one that passed away and my
grandfather gives me a pair of like
alligator shoes they were the most
uncomfortable freakin things I've ever
seen and I look good though no I looked
I look like a 22 year old lost kid whoo
yay Hopalong there who was a philosophy
and religion major who's about a [ __ ]
Wall Street yes yes yes who's gonna
write this amazing critique I knew
nothing okay so I get there and
immediately actually fall in love with
it it was like a meritocracy right it
really wasn't all these high-powered
brains just trying to scam the system
there's a lot of like blue-collar
workers down there on the on the floor
making what is now being done by
computers right like but I fell in love
with it three months into it first Union
offers me a job as a broker spent a year
and a half learning what not to do and
then I landed at a hedge fund mutual
fund shop called horizon kinetics all
right before we get to horizon what did
you learn not to do oh so when most of
the broker trading programs like if
you've seen the movie boiler room or
wolf of Wall Street
yeah those I hate to say it they
everybody thinks it's an exaggeration
it's actually much worse I mean it was
worse than that yeah no way the part of
Wall Street where they're doing the
selling is a horrible part of Wall
Street yeah right those cold calls those
get the client in churn them all that
sort of stuff
it doesn't matter how big the bank is at
least 20 years ago it still existed that
way yeah I can't say it does today cuz I
don't I don't do it anymore and I never
did it I didn't succeed there I've had
people come in and say basically their
job
when they join where these brokerage
they walked in in the morning you know
8:00 8:30 right before the market opens
and the whole goal of the day was 800
aisles yeah let's go yeah and so smile
and dial smile dial and let them keep
going and you just heard no no click no
click no answer no click no answer and
then somebody wanted to talk to you and
it was just reel them in to get them to
buy a stock a hundred percent yes that's
[ __ ] crazy
so so you'll appreciate the North
Carolina connection I'm working at First
Union ok in New York nobody in New York
knows where First Union is everybody in
the South does still had a southern
accent I know you don't believe it now
are you hearing me now sound like you're
Joey from the Bronx yeah all right I
sound like that kid who got me into the
exchange but I was calling North
Carolina businesses and they're telling
me to sell them Global Crossing
convertible preferred or Sun
Microsystems stock or the AOL Time
Warner merger and I'm like what the hell
I can't do this so what I did is I found
these closed-end funds that were
municipals for North Carolinians and I
called every North Carolinian sold them
that and I got my 50 accounts and I did
everything I was supposed to do to get
through the system and then my senior
broker looks at me goes you didn't help
me at all these guys aren't gonna buy
another thing from us you've sold them
the right thing that they got to buy and
hold right so that's what I mean but I
learned what not to do yeah it's almost
like there was a very binary outcome
there either you did something good for
you or you did something good that
that's been the biggest problem with
finance for a long time actually
that's what I do love about ETFs I know
we're gonna get there eventually but
it's that transparency it's that client
alignment that's why I got there
eventually
yeah what what's the craziest thing you
saw like the wolf of Wall Street the
boiler room I call it what's the
craziest thing you saw all right so
there was this one day own Ames
Yahoo names there was this one day where
we were close to the end of some of this
like the markets were crashing and a
couple brokers lost their job and in
protest they ordered 1,000 White Castle
burgers to the floor of the exchange you
didn't see it on TV because they did it
in one of the back rooms there used to
be like six rooms now
only see one there's really two left but
we all only see one and they filled that
room with that just to piss off
Grasso who was the head of the exchange
at that time really yes and then they
had another trick that's not that crazy
well no here's where it gets crazy so
they brought it in the burgers the other
thing is there's no way to get alcohol
into the exchange legally there was a
firm down there not a firm a restaurant
down there that did Red Bulls this is
before we had Red Bull as a energy drink
or whatever yeah a Red Bull back 20
years ago was a tomato soup that was
half vodka so he ordered like two or
three hundred of those as well and was
handing them out and so it did get crazy
right there's like a mountain there like
jumping into this mountain people get
their [ __ ] up on that stock exchange
for and they had their stomachs full
from White Castle yes there was I mean
there's all kinds of crazy things back
there was two clerks that work down
there that sold pornography like videos
back when there wasn't really an
intermediate there's sure there's tons
of we're ready for this so in 2000 and I
think 2010 I actually spent a little bit
of time at the New York Stock Exchange
doing an internship and I didn't know
this but next door to the stock exchange
there's like a building attached to the
actual Stock Exchange it's an office
complex right like executive center and
one of the buildings one of the offices
up there I forget it was like hustler
magazine or something and and that was
like the talk of a bunch of the traders
etc was they were always looking for
excuses how do they go up there because
it was all filled with you know porn and
all this kind of stuff it's it's amazing
what entertained people back then and
back then they had the Superbowl pole
pool there was 10,000 a box really and
one winner 1 million dollars you know
when I was 22 and I'm looking at all
this going wait [ __ ] and most of them
are blue-collar and they're they're
actually just working hard to get him um
but I also watched them all disappear
right when I was down there there was
10,000 of them and now I think there's
like 500 oh I would be surprised as the
identity but yeah yeah yeah they're
still walking around the guy who gave me
my first job down there is still down
there he's are still of
fluor like governor or something like
that I you see him on TV every day ya
know so the other thing that a lot of
people know and I forget the guys name
and I wish I remembered but there's one
guy who has been the overseer of the
Berkshire stock and he's been doing it
for like 20 years or whatever it's been
like basically he's been the one guy and
in 2010 he was still down there and
people would walk over and talk to him
and stuff and he said look there's the
two share classes and he knew everything
but he was mid 70s or maybe even to his
80s then and I remember asked him I said
how are you gonna do this and he goes
why would I stop yeah yeah I mean if the
human intervention is still good and
it's really the guys that do guys and
girls that still work down there they
matter from 9:00 a.m. to 10:30 and then
again from 3:30 to 4:30 in the middle of
the day unless there's a disruption that
that's why there's five hundred instead
of ten thousand yeah so how do you go
from learning everything not to do to
horizon what was that like so horizon
was like eye opening it was such a
different mentality right it was like
they were managing their own money plus
they had this internet fund even though
they didn't believe in the internet but
they they wanted to diversify and it was
all about how do we find things that
everybody else is ignoring actually
that's why they're in crypto now like
they're one of the few our IAS that
actually do it and four or five years in
I went from being the fourth employee
with a company that had a billion to
like the 20th employee with 40 billion
we had 40 billion with 20 employees it
was amazing
in o-5 our biggest position was newmont
mining and we watched it go straight
down like like falling off a cliff but
gold went straight up and we realized it
was because the access has changed right
so GLD the first ever fund that could
give you liquid exposure to gold was
launched right at the end of 2004 and so
all of our big clients the the saw roses
and the Einhorn's who wanted gold
exposure now weren't getting it through
the miners they were getting it directly
through the commodity
um and we realized well Marie and Peter
and them realized I was still pretty
young ETFs are threatening the business
of two-and-twenty ETFs are threatening
the business of 125 on a mutual fund ETF
so threatening pretty much everything
normal in the financial industry
ETFs 10-15 years ago were scaring people
more than crypto so they said how do we
hedge this and there was a boutique firm
so young guy gets the job of how do we
hedge this and it became let's get into
the index business let's become angel
investors and some of the startups we
got very involved with WisdomTree
very involved with emerging Global
Advisors we looked at a number of others
and we said not only we want to invest
in some of these we like incubated them
in our offices to learn that whole
creation Redemption all that sort of
stuff fast forward to 2012 I said time
to do this on my own and I started to
Rosa
what was it what's the biggest thing you
took away from learning to working at
horizon o stay with what you love right
so I loved the research part of horizon
I loved the trading part I loved making
the deals by year 12 I had become in
charge of 20 or 30 people and I had a
person above me and then I managed a
company and then 20 below me and then
the clients and I became a manager of
people not an investment guy anymore and
six months of that was enough for me to
say guys thank you so much but I'm gonna
go start my own company it was nice when
they said well we'd like to invest in it
so you can't leave on better terms than
that yeah absolutely
and so what was the general idea said
hey I want to go do this on my own but
was it I want to go invest in ETS I want
to create ETF site like what was kind of
an original idea that you had that that
really pushed over the edge to leave so
for all your entrepreneurs out there
your first idea sucks your first 10
problems yes
so our idea was nobody has ever looked
at ETF's under the hood they've all said
if it says it's small cap it must be and
I'm gonna buy the cheap small cap one we
thought what if we look and make a
research firm around what's actually in
an ETF right so for example the Vanguard
small cap ETF take her VB if you go look
at it
it's actually like 58% mid-caps so we
thought telling people that they would
give us money to manage mm-hmm
guess what they didn't um it became a
really bad time the other big ETF firms
like F squared and good harbor and wind
Haven they were hitting some hard times
so for the first three years we
completely floundered while we built a
brand around research and content and
technology to look at etf's
we were impossible for us to get in
assets to actually manage of portfolios
of ETFs I think we stayed at 30 million
in AUM for the first three years mm-hmm
miserable so as you're doing that do you
think hey we made a mistake and this
doesn't work or do you think that we
just got to kind of plug 'el uh you know
keep plugging along and then we'll get
more assets like what what's the thought
process that you're going through when
it doesn't take off how you originally
thought it would yeah um you have to
commit to things right you have to give
them their real try but you also can't
walk into that definition of insanity
for too long because then you end up
bankrupt so I would say we kept trying
for three years but we had this one
little piece that was a different angle
we were doing some consulting work for
global X funds using the research and
technology and that helped grow some of
the assets at global X so on that year
three when we said let's keep the
research let's keep the technology but
instead of monetizing it through trying
to get SMA models let's go out and use
this to help other ETF issuers grow and
the very next day we had direction as a
client and then Robo Global is a client
then a mqq as a client today we actually
represent like fourteen or fifteen
issuers and it was just an epiphany
point today
we're eight years old I really yeah we
two years we did a party on the New York
Stock Exchange floor on February 5th
eight years ago to launch the business
congratulations
so it's all like happy birthday yes it's
kind of a happy birth I know that I
didn't realize it till Facebook told me
this morning that uh that this was a
memory and it has the picture of the
exchange of the date damn I would have
got a birthday cakes like an ice cream
cake is my favorite though
so first three years lost yep reposition
two years of getting to sustainability
and the last two or three of finding
scale okay and so what describe what the
business does think you guys have kind
of multiple components too sure so we
have a tree oversee about two billion in
assets we have a traditional wealth
management platform you know five or six
advisers that use ETFs under our
tutelage to help people invest then we
have a traditional asset management
platform where we're the sub advisor of
the active blockchain ETF the active
battery metals ETF the active gig
economy ETF and we still manage some
assets there that you know that's about
600 million as well and then the last
piece is our title ETF services that's
under our umbrella anybody who wants to
launch an ETF they come to us we help
them launch it we help them grow it we
did eight funds last year including some
really innovative things like helping
Blue Cross Blue Shield's equities their
cash in an ETF and helping so fie the
student loan lender launch for ETFs
including the first free ones and those
eight funds raised six hundred and
twenty million in the first year that's
crazy it was a story so describe what
exactly is an ETF cuz I think a lot of
people here ETF they they've seen all
the people on Twitter or CNBC except are
talking about ETFs like what the hell is
an ETF okay so I'm gonna quote one of my
friends Reggie Brown he's I'm the ETF
nerd he gets called the ETF Godfather he
said he's the one who kind of twenty six
years ago helped build all the pipes for
the trading of it down on the American
Stock Exchange and stuff and his
definition of an ETF is it's a mutual
fund with benefits and he says it's very
sultry
so it really is just that simple the the
ETF is created under the same laws and
same regulations as the mutual fund it
really is the exact same structure it is
exempt from one rule and that rule is
that it prices once a day so mutual fund
same thing as in ETF but only prices
once a day ETF prices every second now
once your price every second you get all
these unintentional benefits okay one an
unintentional benefit is you have to
crew you have to be able to create and
redeem intraday which means there's
massive tax benefits so what are those
benefits so an ETF through the creation
and redemption process as long as
there's flows may never generate a
capital gain most of them have it
so if you took the same strategy and had
it in a mutual fund wrapper and an etf
wrapper most likely you're going to get
a superior return after taxes out of the
ETF version got it right it's just a
distribution of taxes so I love ETFs
because they go back to the philosophy
and religion they're transparent they're
liquid they're tax efficient and they
tend to be lower cost because they don't
have all those imbedded fees to pay the
old brokers at first Union that I used
to work with so it really is simply an
access point it is a better technology
it it really reminds me of the
precursors to what blockchain and things
like that are doing to finance now it
really decentralized a lot of the
original investments and so give me some
examples of like the most popular ETFs
right so they're exchange-traded funds
they basically are these baskets if you
will of underlying usually public
securities or liquid assets but like
what are some of the popular ones okay
so this is a great question because I
have an awesome resource for everybody
and it's free so we run this thing
called the ETF think-tank it's literally
ETF think-tank comm and it has on a
daily basis the answers to all those
questions and there's no there's no ads
it's not a paid site we just wanted for
the ETF nerds out there at aggregations
right and on there it'll tell you that
as of today there's four point four
trillion in US dollars in ETFs four
point four trillion four point four
trillion damn okay average expense ratio
19 basis points expenses okay okay so
that's pretty cheap right if you think
about where it's going be open to close
ratio this is one that I love in the
last twelve months for every ETF that
open know for every one point four five
six ETFs that open one closed got it so
net gain every year it has been but it
used to be for every three that open one
closed it's been consolidating the
industry is waking up and saying we
can't just have six ETFs for every
little subcategory I think of it as a
good thing another one that's I love the
quote right now on average ETFs own
seven point five percent of every US
stock in terms of their market ETFs own
seven point five percent of all stocks
placed on the market cap yep when we
started calculating that eight years ago
it was two point six seven got it's a
three three X essentially over the last
seven years for 26 years ETF assets have
grown Allen averaged at nineteen point
six percent so this is a private equity
like kind of growth yeah annualized
annualized this invest in that going up
man I where were you - I did launch an
ETF once to track that okay and it was
you know everybody's came out that's the
meta ETF we had ticker T ETF right T ETF
two years of it out there nobody bought
it why um
because when it's all said and done that
nineteen bits times four point four
trillion only equals about eight billion
in revenue mm-hmm so when people think
of it they know the ETF industry is
growing but they don't see an eight
billion dollar industry as as huge cuter
yeah I mentioned the earlier like the
pet care industry generates fifty
billion yeah so here's one of the
questions I've got right is it seems to
me like straw
during the passive ETFs right so there's
a whole bunch of them let's say just SP
why is an easy one right so the SP 500
I'm basically gonna build that basket
and I'm gonna allow people access
through an ETF structure to put capital
in they don't have to be accredited so
we got accredited accredited kewpie
whatever they want to be they can put
very small amounts of capital in and
also they can redeem intraday exceptions
they can buy sell liquid market at the
whole nine yards once I create that yeah
there's some like blocking and tackling
that goes into making sure that it still
sticks to the index or the construction
stay straight but for the most part its
marketing right like once you get it
there is that would it be fair to say
like that's the difference between
etf's that are successful and
unsuccessful is who's good at marketing
what they've built or their other things
that go into the success and failure of
an ETF so there's one step before okay
and then everything else you said is
100% accurate okay you got to get the
product right like I can't tell you how
many people come to us and go I've got
this idea it's very similar to something
else that's out there but I've got a
better index yep I'm sorry nobody cares
about your index what explain exactly
what that means they they go all right
there's a let's say um there's a there's
a widget ETF out there okay it makes
this widget and it's market cap weighted
right and they're charging 20 basis
points
I'll get people come to me and say hey I
want to do an ETF on that widget but
instead of market cap weighting it
I want to weight it by the revenue of
this times the X of that let make a very
nuance yeah technical component of
change and because I've got this better
index I want to charge 40 bits failure
there's there's no marketing that's
going to make that work yeah all people
look at is you're buying the same widget
you're charging me double the fees
exactly that might work twenty years
from now mm-hmm right because it's how
it happened in the mutual fund industry
you had the simple funds and then people
came out a little more complicated
version and it built on it right now
99% of ETF investors are looking at the
exposure they're not looking under the
hood I thought eight years ago I could
start getting them to look under the
hood I'm eight years in and maybe it's
gone
from 100% won't - now maybe 99 will so
it takes a long time to get people to
look past the name the ticker the
expense ratio you got the name the
ticker the expense ratio right then it's
a hundred percent marketing got it and
so what are the areas that you've seen
that are not the large ones but they're
new that have come out onto the market
that you're like BAM they nailed it like
are there certain sectors that you've
seen that that really get you excited so
uh last year defiance came out with a 5g
fund that was brilliant
okay 5g and how did they construct it
like what's in the underlying assets
it's it's all the companies that are in
I mean they're gonna be in some of the
other indexes as well obviously but it's
the Qualcomm's and all that that are
involved in eight city we're rolling it
out but they packaged it all in one nice
clean sector they worked with a good
indexer not not like um some of these
specialty thematic things you don't
really want to go to the old-school
indexers right cuz they're gonna market
cap it's just substance you want
somebody's gonna think in research so he
used a company called blue star indexes
Steven Schoenfeld the guy was one of the
original portfolio managers at Blackrock
25 years ago so he's been doing this
forever and they built an interesting
index nobody cares
until they actually buy it and then the
guy in charge of the firm just poured
all the money into marketing it you
anybody who goes in Google's 5g tomorrow
you're going to be chased by the CTF
everywhere else you go yeah right is
that is paid marketing and digital
marketing a big part of the ETF world
now a hundred percent yes real um I
would have thought that it was much more
what I would call not dumb as in like
it's stupid but like dumb is in not
intelligent data-driven marketing so
like how do I get on television how do I
write a blog like that type of stuff not
so much like I know that I spent $3 and
I get a customer and that customer is
worth you know twenty seven dollars and
it's more like data-driven acquisition
so it when I was at Global X we started
right away into this space cuz actually
my partner Guillermo Trias had invested
in some of these digital marketing firms
most asset managers won't even touch
digital market yep
the ETF space it's different right
because it is decentralized
there isn't an intermediary that we have
to go through right like if the end
client wants to buy it they log into
their account and buy it
whereas with hedge funds mutual funds
SMAS they got to talk to some old boring
person to help them get to the end
investment so at global X we did things
like ticker targeting right so if we had
a competitive fund to somebody else and
they looked up on Yahoo Finance that
competitive fund yep guess what our ad
showed up yep right nobody had thought
to do that in the in the finance world
when we started talking to the
regulators about it and our compliance
or like you know I mean you know how it
is most hedge funds they don't want to
talk to the press
yeah you know with the ETF's you want
the masses to know cuz you're a hundred
percent transparent yeah you're
basically marketing to the masses and
therefore any way you can get to them
whether it's through kind of the
broad-based let me go on television let
me write a blog let me tweet whatever
all the way down to how do I actually
run a Facebook ad campaign to get you to
convert yeah and it better be
educational like like if you if you just
try and say buy my thing it doesn't work
right show me a growth story
show me how you're capturing it show me
you know mmm that I want this like when
we did the originally launched the
blockchain ETF we were watching the
Google AdWords for blockchain and
knowing that there's this demand people
want to figure out how to get this right
so you know it was so much of a demand
that the SEC was scared enough to not
let us call it blockchain so tell me
this story this story of kind of what
you guys the thought process and how you
guys created that original blockchain
DTF okay
so uh this is another one of those my
partner's faster than I am at this stuff
so I had for our SMA accounts been
buying some blockchain stocks grow hive
I had bought some gbtc sold it every
time it went up because I was scared to
death of the premium and he kept saying
why don't we do an ETF of this why don't
we do an ETF of this and I kept saying
there's not enough companies
can't make an index and all of a sudden
there was this epiphany a friend of ours
called us and said I've built an index
but it's not really investable and he's
but I'm working with this other firm
they want to do it but they need
somebody to make it investable and all
of a sudden we said alright the three of
us are gonna do it together and we're
gonna do it active and that was the
epiphany was you know three years ago
when we first started this you couldn't
really do a passive version of this and
get anything that's a real blockchain
company it was the fastest we've ever
moved in our lives we went from agreeing
to do it to filing in eleven days Wow
that's especially with memory partners
we that doesn't happen fast but we all
saw it and we all trusted each other and
it's been great and so it's important to
call out here the difference between
these passive and active ETFs what what
is that okay so I talked about mutual
funds with benefits earlier so the first
benefit has always been the low-cost
that people point to and over the last
three or four years people realized hey
doesn't have to be passive to be
low-cost and it doesn't have to be
passive to be an ETF and I will say the
pioneer here is Katherine Loyd a narc
what she did to bring active management
into the world of ETFs is brilliant
because not only did she make it viable
by being good at what she does she did
something even more important that goes
back to your marketing points with the
mutual fund you only know what you own
like 35 or 45 days later so you're not
allowed to talk about what you out with
an ETF you tell what you own every 15
seconds so rather than find that as a
challenge Katherine embraced it and said
since everybody knows what I owned every
15 seconds I'm gonna talk about it mm-hm
right so she took what most active
managers would see as a negative
embraced it and ran with it so today we
have plenty of active ETFs in fact
active ETFs represent about 3% of the
assets in ETFs today but represents six
percent of the revenue really yeah so
you can see why people might be
attracted yeah yeah absolutely and cathy
has been on the on the podcast
foreign I think part of what has made
her so successful is not only one her
investment and kind of conviction she
has but in the marketing but also on top
of that she really embraces the idea
that anyone can critical participate by
kind of open sourcing and open allowing
participation in her research meetings
etc and it's just a very different way
to think about asset management then
kind of traditionally has been done a
hundred percent like I've never
understood these people who say I need
to have a lack of transparency in order
to have alpha mmm-hmm well then you
don't really have alpha yeah so I love
that she's saying I'm gonna bet on
innovation and my team and I'm gonna
tell everybody what I'm doing cuz I got
no secret she she has embodied the
values of the ETF structure yep
it's amazing it wasn't easy you know but
I'm very happy for yeah absolutely and
so as you look at the passive versus
active you guys decided to go with the
active model for the blockchain ETF what
was going into that actual ETF like when
people think of blockchain companies
most of them are private not public
absolutely and that that was really hard
in the beginning it's why you know my
partner Guillermo kept saying build it
build it and I kept saying it's not
ready not ready and then the Epiphany of
going active was oh if I'm active I can
buy IPOs 30 days later from active I can
buy a hundred million dollar market caps
so for example last year there was three
or four IPOs that I would call very
close to pure plays in the blockchain
space which were my absolute favorite
right now is silver gate probably half
the people listening to you have banked
with them because how lanes been on you
yeah like they they are the bank right
they went public in December right it
trades at a discount to what normal
banks do I'm at some point when the big
banks want to really get in there
they're gonna have to build it or they
just buy silver gate like that's a great
one cannon you know Asics chips maker
like pure play minor and chip baker yep
one connect financial these are
something that you know came out last
year but we've also got things like
hoodie
five galaxy digital Novogratz this
company I mean it's a merchant banking
company mm-hmm you know their stakes and
ethos and stakes and honey it's takes in
all of it
GMO internet I mean they're they're just
cranking away a lot of what we own at
the top are these large Japanese firms
like GMO and Z holdings and and digital
digital garage mm-hmm
that primarily are doing stable coins
and getting into the decentralized
finance or they're building exchanges so
I think the original negatives that
everybody talked about these are just
chips companies or these are just big
Fang names not so much anymore right
there's if I look through my top ten
you know there's maybe two names that
the average investor would recognize for
sure what is as you look out at the
space what are the things that are
coming down the pipe that are in the
private markets that you're saying hey
when this gets into public market
investors hands or they can get exposure
you lived through ETFs right or
otherwise you're like that's gonna be a
really big moment so in terms of the the
public companies I think it's gonna be
the spin-offs okay explain so right now
you have awesome things that are 10 20
30 % of big companies revenue mm-hm and
standalone they're a pure play Bach
chain company right so I think we're
gonna see spin-offs of JP Morgan that's
their blockchain business or IBM that's
their blockchain business or backed
being spun out of ice right like I think
that's the play play because a lot of
the private stuff is partially owned by
SBI holdings or Softbank or digital
garage or you know Accenture has an arm
here and Citigroup's invested here JP
Morgan
they all have taken these little stakes
you know master cards gone all-in I
think that for the public markets that's
that's the net now the other end of it
you know whenever we talk ETFs everybody
wants to know about the Bitcoin ETF
right um I think that's what everybody's
waiting for ironically we don't see that
as a threat to
we built the blockchain ETF block is a
hedge against crypto as alone okay
explain explain this first as why do you
feel like block is not threatened by a
Bitcoin ETF because block is the
technology it's the companies making
money off of it if there is a Bitcoin or
cryptocurrency ETF some day block will
become like GD x so GD X is the gold
miner ETF and GL D is the gold ETF so
people who want to own the protocol will
buy the Bitcoin ETF and people who want
to use by the pynx axes and utilization
of the protocol will buy the blockchain
ETF got it and as you think about the
Bitcoin ETF like what's your analysis of
kind of where we are today
I know we're investors in in bit wise
obviously they've got one of the
applications in and a mutual friend of
mine yours is hunter yeah kind of what
what is the the thought process there as
to how that plays out so I've been a
little controversial on this if there
was a crypto ETF I would buy it I would
buy it for my clients I think it would
be quite controversial well here's where
it gets controversial the part is I
don't think it's good for crypto okay
explain that
so Kryptos part of the original mission
is to get rid of the trusted third party
right like that is that is part of why
we want to decentralize network that
said we have this whole group of
investors that are waiting to get in
until the trusted third party of an ETF
and the SEC says it's okay right so the
reality is it's a contradiction right
the SEC is saying when these markets are
clean and we can follow them and all
that sort of stuff then we'll let you
put it in an ETF okay all right so let
me give you a scenario there's a couple
people who have said this to me I'm not
saying that you are wrong but let's take
cash for example US Dollars I can own
that in a decentralized self sovereign
way I can have physical cash right I got
money right here in my pocket or I can
take these same dollars and I can put
them into an electronic version in a
bank via a centralized third party right
yep and I can get exposure through
multiple ways to the same asset but it's
my choice right I could take all every
dollar that I own and I could put it all
into physical cash and hide underneath
my bed or I can go use essentialize
third parties if I could only have it in
one format either or right it would
drastically limit the access sure
Bitcoin in my opinion is similar in that
I can own Bitcoin directly right i can
self custody it and kind of do all the
things that it's kind of that bitcoin
ethos that you're talking about which
without a doubt is super important and
should be encouraged but there is some
percentage of the population I don't
care how much education you they'll
never do it right and so when you add in
a Bitcoin ETF all of a sudden you're
just giving another way to access so
it's not so much that I disagree with
you it's I don't know if it's going to
be as big of a moment as people want it
to be right because they're still the
people who own Bitcoin today alright
then I can just go buy Bitcoin ETF no am
I gonna go pay for it when I've already
got it yeah when I already have it
exactly so that's one and then two is
you're actually just gonna bring in the
people who probably are gonna go buy it
directly like I keep going back to
anyone who knows about Bitcoin and has
made the decision to invest went and
bought it right figuring that they're
not good waiting around for the ETF in
my opinion right maybe there's some
people who are like yeah we haven't made
the decision yet but if an et I've got
approved then we would do it but if
people have decided to invest yeah it's
difficult to go to coin base or to go to
Gemini or go to you know block fire
whoever but it's not that difficult no
it's not the reality is the reason most
people want it is so that advisors can
charge fees on it of course yeah it
helps yeah so it's it to me it's like
it's like they're signing their own
death warrant alright so um I get the
question and this is kind of connected
what is the biggest threat to ETF's it's
this the blockchain right like once
every security is tokenized why would
you need an ETF why would you need half
the the 500 people left on the stock
exchange right that's why people like NY
IC are investing in
backed and things like that so it's the
same contradiction but it's it's
important to talk about it because if
the average person is going to buy the
Bitcoin ETF or the crypto ETF as a
speculation they need to know that the
reason it has value is because it's
going to replace that whole system
mm-hmm right like it is going to replace
the ETF if it works and that's when it's
gonna be worth an insane amount of money
yeah what what do you feel like right
now is the general sentiment of folks
that are buying ETFs or are they saying
I can't wait for the Bitcoin ETF or is
that something that's more like the
crypto community is waiting for and they
think it's a big deal but people outside
of crypto could care less um it will it
will likely cause the price to go up
because it will be a massive demand I
you do you say you do think that there's
an I think it's a billion dollar fund
within three months I think there is a
lot of demand mm-hmm right because they
look we think the fee looks like on that
a reasonable one or what is likely I
think somebody could probably charge
close to 1% because there's gonna be
huge loss you think that 1% so 100 basis
points where is the traditional fee
structure right now is on average around
19 or 20 basis but that's asset weighted
right so if I if I look at like the
robotics ETF that's done with extremely
low that's at 95 bits okay so are ones
that have high high air quotes because
when you have you know spwhy at 2 or 300
billion at 7 bits 9.45 bits I love that
now now now they're rounding the 1/2
pips so that it you know it's almost 10
but it really gets quoted is 9 it's very
smart what they do nowadays but when you
have a quarter trillion dollars at 9
bits that takes the whole average down
but there are plenty like arc I think is
at 70 bits nobody has any problem with
that
um or maybe 75 hour blockchain ETF is at
70 bits nobody's complaining there we're
doing a lot of active research we got to
sit down with Novogratz and overstock
and and the Japanese companies digital
garage meet all the IRS figure out if
riots
company or not like they'll we're being
paid for doing the research absolutely
and so when you look at that
eateat bitcoin etf gets approved billion
dollar fund in a couple of months you're
driving in our billion dollars that's
probably a 10 million dollar revenue
business give or take for somebody
what yeah but if it keeps going up okay
so I think is thinking like what does it
grow into though right you're talking
about two hundred and fifty billion
dollars in ETF world today like how big
could something like that get a Bitcoin
ETF so the problem is there's there's
two variables here right so there's the
variable of probably raises a billion
dollars in three or four months and then
you get the price run-up right that's
part of why the SEC is being so careful
yep we're saying a billion dollars of
capital inflow into the ETF they didn't
have so they have to go buy Bitcoin yep
well also you get a billion dollars
flowing into the asset it's only 160
hundred seventy billion dollar asset
today there's price movement now you see
the price moving then people start
chasing right you can see very quickly
how here we go into this parabolic run
but at the same time the SEC wants to
protect people from getting caught up in
that mania 100 percent yet they saw the
the Long Island blockchain our Long
Island eta with T was it Long Island
iced tea long have an iced tea
blockchain things so like they changed
the name to blockchain like overnight
yeah literally this stock will just
explode exploded and that was like two
weeks before we launched our blockchain
ETF right and two days before we
launched they called us and said you
can't use the word blockchain in the
name really yes because they saw the the
mania that was happening yep now for us
honestly it was one of the best things
that could happen there's an irony here
because we had a great ticker BL okay
everybody knew what it was what is it
actually called the amplified
transformational data sharing ETF Jesus
Christ when they amplified data sharing
amplify transformational data sharing
ETF I don't think I've said that in two
and a half years yeah aka blocks
I mean but I understand that the the
regulator's are there to protect the
public right and they did you know but
anybody who went and looked at we owned
they knew what they we on we showed our
holdings yep um so but at that time they
were protecting so when they look at
this stuff they're always looking to
protect because there's no upside in it
for them right well what is the upside
for them to bring in this new technology
it's they've got enough to write Haley
yeah so it has to actually prove itself
out and here's the irony back to the
statement earlier I think once it proves
itself out I don't think you'll people
will need the ETF anymore I agree you
know I agree we'll see let's see um when
do you think he gets approved Oh does
the ETF get approved while J Clayton's
in office I don't know um that's a
cop-out answer no no well I'm gonna give
I'm gonna give a little more I would
have bet this year because this year
meaning 2019 or 2020 2020 okay 2020
we're recording this February 2020
yep so I would have bet February 2020
because we've seen the interval funds
get approved and and I see trading and
markets starting to understand it but
then as I talked to a lot of the
regulators directly on other things they
don't seem to see a reason to get here I
always thought that the first product
was gonna be futures based and then you
had you know CBOE futures kind of fail
so like I don't you know they wouldn't
do the VIX products until the futures
were trading well they're not gonna do
this as so all the things that I thought
were gonna get it there all right here's
the wild card we got our having coming
we don't know what's gonna happen I love
your warnings on Twitter all the time
you know got to be careful and got to do
your own research I agree with it but
listen cuz here's why you ready because
I people accuse me all the time of never
saying negative things or never saying
the warnings and so I say you know what
fine everyone that's your biggest knock
against me I'm gonna periodically tweet
you know what I'm gonna tweet it out
while we're strong on requires right now
is that I'm gonna periodically tweet out
saying don't invest all your money do
your own research all the things that
people
want to be that people don't want to
hear but need to be told hey Lilly I
mean it's you have to know what your own
like that's that's what I love about
this whole ETF think it shows you what
your own there's no secrets and you know
I don't want to be the the bull here and
say oh the crypto winter is coming to an
end and the having's coming but that's
the wild card
do you not you don't think it's over I I
am well I'm so on the record here that
I'm afraid to say how bullish I alright
well tell us some of why you're bullish
I just I see the actual companies
involved actually using the technology
not for [ __ ] anymore right so angry
when I first started doing the actual
company research I go there I talked to
the ir department and blockchain was
like ESG to them yeah it was like to
talk about it
we need our block change strategy so
that we can get some headlines never
pays attention yeah and so I was like ah
you know how do I buy this
there's a little bit here I got a seat
and now when I talked the second time I
going back to talk to them
it was we've got a utility token the
utility token era drove me insane and
that was basically when everything was
crashing right utility token this
utility token that and then in the last
call it 18 months I've watched so much
happen with security token and actual
finance things and and actual
transactions happening and I mean even
overstock despite all the headaches that
come with that what they did with the
token dividend forced certain parts of
the financial system we've never thought
about this to think about it it and we
traded through it like it was not easy
so I am bullish because although that I
don't see the full killer app yet other
than the cross-border I see it coming
because there are actual real projects
now it's not it's not just hey we set it
at our IR meetings so that we got some
SEO and SEM on it and you know for sure
what um what's the worse
part of the etf industry there's a lot
of good things there's a lot of things
that obviously are great for investors
they're great for the asset managers
what do you think is like the dark side
of the ETF industry oh man I'm gonna
piss people off you know yeah I'm just
channeling what I'm thinking to him so
he's only gonna repeat what I say no no
I'll just tell the truth because I
philosophy religion transparency we're
all there its gatekeepers man it's when
this started the ETF's could be bought
anywhere it when I decentralized it was
just like a stock over the years the
bigger firms and it's every one of them
have figured out how to put up gates to
prevent investors that are acting or
using them as an intermediary from
accessing new innovative ideas and then
they're asking the older firms that they
already have relationships with to clone
those ideas so give me an example of
what like a gate would look like a gate
would look like Bank XYZ says you can't
buy this ETF because it's from a new
issue or who we haven't approved Oh got
it but if you really want it we'll call
this issue or that we already have
business with and asked them to create a
clone of it got it right innovation
basically they take the idea they hand
it to the big asset manager the big
asset managers that you're not gonna get
fired with going with IBM type model I
cover my ass you as the investor you're
gonna get the same exposure the big
asset manager loves us cuz we're
bringing them capital we cover our ass
you're not gonna fire us but the person
who gets screwed is that person with the
innovative idea who's creating the the
small ETF a hundred percent yeah and you
got to understand ETFs are taking a
massive business model away from these
big banks right they make a ton of money
on these mutual funds and their that
fees not book banked into ETF so they
deserve the right to figure out a due
diligence to figure out this or that but
I don't like that it comes at the cost
of innovation mmm-hmm great like to me
that I always say there's two things
pushing the growth of ETFs we talked a
lot about client alignment factors as a
tax efficient
the transparency liquidity low-cost all
that the other one is innovation growth
factors okay
ETFs made gold accessible ETFs made
leverage accessible ETS have made by
right successful ETFs have made robotics
and blockchain accessible its yes will
probably eventually make crypto
accessible you start stifling that
innovation and then we're just back to
to the making 800 dials a day yeah it up
on it's pretty crazy
yep right what um what what else do you
think about the blockchain crypto space
so what are you excited about outside
ETS okay so my favorite thing about
blockchain is it takes the the values
that I've talked about in ETFs to the
next level and I love how the next
generation is going to embrace this so I
have three children
they're now eight ten and twelve and
each one of them got a Bitcoin two or
three years ago at like 850 bucks mm-hmm
so that means every day they look at it
they know the price right and to me that
tells me this is really going to work
because they're watching all the YouTube
videos they're understanding it mice
mice eight year old he was seven at the
time but he has a Raspberry Pi he went
and built a Bitcoin miner after watching
a YouTube video it didn't work he really
didn't know what he was doing but he
plugged a bunch of wires together and
and put it there and I was so proud of
him
I know show it to ya listeners can't see
it for the youtubes I bought this for
seven bucks online said it's a gold coin
that has the Bitcoin beyond it yeah it's
basically a piece of metal it's worth
seven dollars but I stuck it on his
Raspberry Pi and when he came home from
school he's like oh my god it worked
but because of that I think I'm gonna
buy him a coin mine for his birthday oh
let's go so what's interesting though is
the kids didn't they don't question
whether this is the thing no no I of
course it's up there of course like they
don't watch TV
Yeah right they watch their their
screens and and they don't they they
don't have the same misconceptions that
we have they're not walking in with this
idea that the government has to tell me
it's worth something so every time I
talked to one friend he has two kids
they're around 10 11 and then probably
13 14 so kind of between the ages of 10
and 15 I was like I say who it is but
but a good friend of mine and he says
that his kids are the ones who convinced
him to buy more Bitcoin I think they
don't actually say like hey dad go buy
more Bitcoin but the way that they talk
about it he's like this is absolute like
I'm so [ __ ] bullish because like my
kids don't question yeah right and and
it's interesting to see you know kids
when they see technology won they're
better using it like you ever seen like
a six-year-old using a iPhone they know
everything
my son sets up like iPhone stores in the
basement of all our old broken ones and
he knows like he'll he'll list out the
iPhone 11 does this and that the debt
that I have no idea what you're talking
about but crazy yeah and but but they
just they understand what's gonna work
and what's yes right which is which is
pretty cool and they don't care about
you know who is Satoshi Nakamoto or all
the all the BS we deal with with trying
to explain to somebody who's you know 80
years old they buy things in video games
um yeah so fortnight bucks at the V
bucks oh my god I hate V bucks but like
because it's like he gets a Christmas
present and all I wants to do is buy V
bucks but I get it that he's acclimated
now YUM
I know like my friends over at galaxy
digital they keep telling me look at the
cryptos that are working in gaming yeah
because those are gonna be very I don't
know Mike is real bullish on ya thing I
think yeah you she keeps talking about
it - yo she man shoutout to you he's
very helpful with us with block you know
the kids get it though and they don't
they don't slow down and that tells me
it's gonna get there actually we did
have a story to talk about that I
promised I'd tell you
let's say they kind of links in here so
I mentioned the kids don't care who
created it yep and I love but I always
explained that the fact that we don't
really know who created it is awesome
but this is one of those scenarios that
people don't a lot of history buffs
might know but this is a his history not
repeating but rhyming there's this story
of Nicolas Bourbaki okay Nicolas
Bourbaki was a Napoleonic general who
lost like multiple Wars or multiple
battles I guess so he didn't lose the
full war he got exiled to some Island
tried to kill himself failed at that
like he was like the known as the
failure alright that was you know a
couple hundred years ago and in France
that was the name the elements of
algebra all the volumes that create the
original text for how algebra works
written in France are all authored by
Nicolas Bourbaki really know it so it's
the same as Satoshi it's a group of
people who didn't want to have credit
for it really yes I did not know that
yeah so modern algebra uh-huh is written
by a group of mathematicians in France
and they claim the author is Nicolas
Bourbaki all the way through because
they didn't want to be identified
because they wanted people to adopt it
and not question the authors not be like
oh this guy has this opinion because
he's trying to sell that paper or they
saw that yeah does a poor French accent
[Laughter]
yeah he's got back from France they're a
little bit rude I must say that the
stereotype is true depends where you go
but that idea is really interesting
because when you when you look at the
removal of the creator' yeah it does
drastically increase the likelihood of
people will adopt something I love it
it's a give the ego away Marty bent
calls it the Immaculate Conception
beautiful right which is a you know
little Fiat is religion and so is any
money yeah and so you have to have a
belief system somewhere I mean for sure
what uh where can people find you on the
Internet
um so there's a at Michael underscore
Venuto
on Twitter I'm pretty active there ETF
think-tank calm is probably the best
place to get our unbiased content right
and then we have plenty other websites
where we're doing and selling stuff but
I'd rather you find me where we're
educating where we're acting as a baba
key or a Nakamoto I love it I love it Oh
before I finished up rapid-fire what's
the most important company in crypto hmm
most important company in crypto in
terms of public like what we're dealing
with whatever public private I mean I
guess from an adoption standpoint right
now even though it's not the core I
think its fidelity or backed like from
from getting to people understanding
this and actually using it in the
finance world mhm you think they're he's
custody yeah that's that's the big thing
what's your most controversial thought
in crypto who the head of Bitcoin ETF is
a contradiction to the overall concept
so that's controversial for everyone
except for the hardcore baby owners
exactly right I guess I guess I guess my
price targets um
maybe outside of the crypto world
whenever people say well why do you have
Bitcoin I go one I believe in it - its
bug out money
III okay I said yeah yeah I do believe
if I've got to go to Europe if I got to
go to Latin America I want to know I got
a hundred grand that's probably gonna be
worth way more than that in that
scenario
mm-hm what um what's the one law or
regulation that you would change or
improve in finance oh so there's a lot
of ridiculous ones out there I think
probably the biggest ones have to do
with what taxes right I I think that the
tax code as it applies to investment
should be changed to promote good
investor behavior people who trade in
and out should be punished right from
the tax code and people who buy and hold
and do it as an investment should be
rewarded the ETF does some of that but
there's plenty of other parts of Finance
that are left out yeah it's it's kind of
like on a 10,000 foot view they've done
it correctly but when you get into the
detail
that's where it gets good it gets messy
quick yeah absolutely I could list a
hundred other little ones but they don't
matter to the average investor taxes eat
away taxes or fees what uh what's the
most important book you've ever read so
uh I always like to give to hear cuz I
have my fiction one and my investment
one fiction city of glass so we
mentioned North Carolina earlier city of
glass helped bring me back to New York
it's Paul Auster's book it's part of the
New York trilogy if you haven't read it
it's it's worth reading especially if
you love how New York City works but it
also candles language and city of glass
city of glass by Paul Auster okay and
then what about the investing book I
have to go with a classic because he's
been somewhat of a mentor to me is
random walk down Wall Street burton
malkiel's helped us with our business
over the years and there's two things i
love about it he lays out the math case
for buying and holding and then at the
end of the book and in an edition number
ten eleven twelve he starts talking
about where there's inefficiencies and
how to do it so he's not an ideologue i
hate people who come out and said this
is the only way to do something um I
love that he's laid out why indexation
works and why it's a base and then he's
laid out why active works were there's
inefficiencies makes complete sense
aliens believer probably not a believer
that there's extended life why I just
don't see how there isn't I think it's
just the world spite like the galaxy is
too big yeah I mean I don't know I don't
want to get too weird but no super
[ __ ] right this can't be the only
dimension there's I've met plenty of
people that probably have a zipper on
the back of their neck you know like you
think that it's a simulation no no
simulation
I don't feel the simulation I I feel
there's multiple parallels there's
multiple there's too much space for us
to be the only consciousness yeah well I
think we have too much hubris to think
that out of all the living beings that
we could see on this planet that we're
the only ones that are actually woke
yeah I think it's crazy when you start
thinking about like we don't need to go
off the planet to find
yeah the the other life absolutely yeah
I I saw recently another video on
Twitter of this [ __ ] thing in the
ocean even know what it was but I'm
telling you that [ __ ] ain't nothing that
we learned about in school
yeah well because it was moving in all
weird directions it was changing colors
it was doing all kinds of crazy stuff
there's so we've talked about some of my
weird stuff with chests and debate and
ETFs and crypto and woke this the other
thing I love to do is fish I do that
what my kids were on the sea all the
time I've been 100 miles out to sea
overnight for three or four days you see
weird weird stuff really like yeah
what's the weirdest thing you see I mean
I've seen I've seen swordfish come up
with like a squid chasing them and it's
supposed to be the other way around and
there's lights like there's no light out
there but you see it coming up from the
depths with lights
I saw a where's the light coming from
the fish oh they're bioluminescent this
we does have bioluminescence and then I
saw this one time a lobster pot I pulled
up on 80 miles off the coast of New York
and there's a fin on it and I don't what
is this I pull up and it's a shark that
was like eight feet long that bit the
rope and got his teeth stuck in it
I spent a half hour getting this shark's
teeth off the like you see crazy thing
is nature yeah and I could have just
kept going yeah and I wanted to save
that shark do you like do you have you
have Instagram no my kids do and they
keep telling me about it alright don't
don't tell them what I'm about to tell
you you don't want them watching this
but if you just go on you know your
browser mmm go to WWE so Graham calm
nature is metal and the Tal it's just
absolute savagery in nature it's just
complete violence of animals eating each
other tracking each other to just [ __ ]
that you would look at and be like it is
a daily reminder of how humans are just
soft right if you think of us as an
animal compared to actual the wild the
things that go on in nature most humans
don't want to see oh yeah I hear you I
think my kids have showed me some of
these videos
I mean I was I was in Florida at the TF
conference and a like 9:00 a.m. I just
get a picture of a giant tuna and mice
from my son and he's like look at the
size of this fish like they just they
just love it yeah it's awesome what
question you got for me to end this
thing
Oh question for you
you know what I've heard so many of your
pods so I kind of know the answers to a
lot of them whatever you got it I got it
what question have you not been asked
that you've always wanted to be there's
a debate skill yeah the question that I
haven't been asked I'm more surprised
that people don't ask about my
motivations for certain things or they
don't at that everyone wants to ask like
the easy soft questions yeah no one
really asks like super hard questions
the people who have so like I'll give a
shout-out to Matt O'Dell Matt Odell came
in and he had very specific questions he
was like you know why are you doing this
right in that something so like he
defecates credit there and then meltem
the first time that we did the interview
meltem d'amours came in and she pushed
back on some stuff etc and like what
people don't realize is like I kind of
enjoy that more he's like people come
and ask like kind of like softball kind
of like well what do you think's gonna
have a Bitcoin like okay everyone's
kinda already heard that right yeah I
listen to your AMA on the train right in
today yeah yeah I know that you to it
says I guy I can't think of a question
but it's interesting to hear how you
just described that yeah because I think
that's why you've been successful with
this is because it's genuine of course
right like people if people were sitting
here going pump is selling something
yeah yeah so like he's right so I tell
people behind closed doors I have no
problem saying sellout this is the most
selfish thing I do and everyone thinks
about it as that's so nice he creates so
much Kahn no [ __ ] no I'm learning every
single conversation I have and I'm
writing every morning it forces me to
put my thoughts I'm tweeting I'm seeing
the way people interact with it like I'm
getting all of these inputs and signals
and feedback and critiques and it helps
me it
rate what I think and kind of have a
more thorough thesis and so like it's
selfish in that standpoint if I wasn't
learning anything in these conversations
I wouldn't have another conversation but
I just see yeah but the fact that I then
record them and I post them and people
find value great like that way that's a
second-order effect but this is the most
selfish thing I do by far okay so and
they want to edit this you just go back
and say Mike's gonna ask the question
why do you do these pods no let's leave
it all in though we don't some answer we
might do a behind-the-scenes video to
post on YouTube because Joe's got his
little studio set up we got the Mevo
camera we've got lights we we got it
laughter think about this it's a two
hundred and twenty something episodes
before we got a [ __ ] light note right
but we got a light in the room now we're
ready to rock and roll next time I want
makeup yeah there will never be any
makeup but the next thing I got to do is
we got to get the some art for the wall
or some of the foams up for the echo I
don't think there's much echo but I
think we we played jeopardy on that
question yeah he saved the answer I gave
the question afterwards that's fine all
right man listen I appreciate you coming
in and doing this you guys have done a
ton of [ __ ] in the ETF worlds I
appreciate giving us a run down there
people can go check out our ETF think
tank comm check out the block ETF and
wat deuce again in the future
this has been a blast absolutely there
we go
thank you